Uh,
so we're talking about a oxidation
oxidizing and reducing reagents and about
alcohols and grin yar reactions to make
them. And if we have time at the end,
we'll get to a little bit
about green chemistry. Uh,
I've,
maybe you should apologize a little bit
about the last question on the exam. I,
I got carried away. I wanted to have
something that was relevant and, uh,
at least historically relevant so that
I could have chosen a better NMR problem
probably. But I wanted to show you
why it's a neat story. So I had,
I showed you a, during the
exam, this, a dissertation from,
from the University of Michigan in 1921
and notice it's about the color of free
radicals. Uh, it was found
originally that the, that the, um,
solutions were colored. Have any of
you ever had a colored solution in lab?
Have you, had any of you ever not
had a colored solution in lab?
Right there always colored.
So at first people put no, uh,
pay no attention to it.
But after they got good at doing it,
they observed that the solutions
were colored sort of a yell,
reddish yellow. But when you s swirled
the thing, the color went away,
it was called this, but then it came
back then just swirled it again.
It went away and came back,
went away, came back, went away,
came back several times.
And so this was something that required
an explanation of what the color was and
how it went away. So on page eight
of this, of this dissertation,
there's this thing up on top that as a
sort of a complicated scheme seems so at
the time at least, uh, to
explain the color, right?
So the idea is that a what, what compound
is a, in this, can you see what it is?
Hey, up at the top left,
let's try fennel, fennel,
fennel, ethane, right. That's what
Gomberg set out to make. Remember.
And then what's to the right of it?
What's B?
It's to try fennel methyl radicals.
Okay.
That's what he decided he had made
on the basis of their reactivity.
But he's drawn something
else here. Uh, down below it,
he explains the color by drawing what
we would regard as a resonance structure
of the free radical, which
puts the, the radical, uh,
out on the para position of one of the
benzene rings and draws other double
bonds there. Uh, and that's they,
the theory then was that when you had
that double bond and two double bonds
conjugated like that,
that caused color, right?
So he explained the color
by saying that it was,
that it was what we would say a resonance
form, but he said in equilibrium,
a forum that was colored and the idea
was that the radical was colored but very
reactive,
but it was in equilibrium with the dimer
and the dimer was not colored light.
Tetra fennel, methane, right.
Was not color. Okay. But the,
but the monomer reacts
quickly with oxygen.
So when you swirl the flask and
let oxygen get into the solution,
it immediately destroys the
colored stuff that in his opinion,
the Quinn oid form this,
these double bonds, right?
The resonance structure we would say,
but it destroys the free radical
then exhausts the oxygen.
Right.
And then if you let it sit a while,
the color comes back cause the equilibrium
between the dimer and the monomer
reestablishes itself. So the color
gets back. But if you swirl it again,
you've got oxygen and it destroys it.
You can keep doing that until you've
used up all the radical. So that was the,
that's how color got into the,
to the act.
Right now, the Nmr I tried, I, I, uh,
asked you to explain and the number of
people got it is the dimer of trifle
mouthful was finally measured by Nmr in,
in 1968. And here's a
spectrum of it. And you see,
it can't possibly be hex a fan,
I'll ethane because it's got one group
of 25 hydrogens and other have to another
of two and another one,
right?
So if we look at Hexcel fan, LFA and of
course you should have six phenol groups,
six times five is 30. There should just
be that one peak. So this obviously,
isn't that,
what is it right that x a fennel ethane
is the product of Alpha Alpha coupling,
the two radical carbons coming together.
But notice what could have happened.
It's obviously not that,
but if you had the funnel
methyl radical up there at B,
and if we use a line instead of a.to
denote the extra valence that's not being
used, and over here draw
the the resonance structure,
which has its extra
valence out at the right,
then you could imagine those are of
course it just resonance structures.
But you could imagine two of them coming
together like that to form this dimer.
So a different dimer.
What advantage would it
have over what disadvantage,
what had have compared
to hexa fennel ethane?
How about this ring here?
Right?
We've lost the aromatics
stability of the ring, right?
What have we gained
in what?
So that's a way in which this dimer
would be worse than x, a fennel ethane.
Is there any way in
which it would be better?
It's less sterically
hindered, right? And Spirit.
Kendra's counts for a lot of these things.
Although that was much appreciated
really until after 1950 so,
okay. When people had talked about
it since the time of Victor Meyer,
but it really didn't convince any one
that you should think about another dimer
rather than hexa fennel ethane.
So anyhow, if you think,
if you consider this structure,
notice that you have
the explanation for uh,
two hydrogens here, the blue ones,
two hydrogens here, the green ones,
a hydrogen here,
the the red one.
And you have coupling between
these two of about 10 hertz.
So it's a double doublet,
right?
And it's distorted that because the,
that there's 60 megahertz spectrum,
that chemical shift difference isn't
large compared to the, to the j coupling.
So the inner peaks are large
and the outer peaks are small.
But if you look even more carefully,
you can see that there's a three hertz
coupling between the red hydrogen and
degree.
And there's a little bit of doublet
splitting here in a little bit of doublet
splitting here. Just it's
hard to see. And in fact,
in some related samples,
you can see a little coupling between
this hydrogen and that one as well.
And these therefore are a little bit
split, but not enough that you can see it.
Why don't you see the splitting in that
one? If a splits be, we should split a,
because this hydrogen is being split into
a triplet by these and into us into a
small triplet by these only three hertz
and then into even smaller triplets by
these,
right?
So it's just a whole bunch of peaks on
top of one another that just looked like
a lump out here.
So it's quite clear what this structure
is at this that it's this Quinoa dimer
once you have the Nmr to see it.
Okay,
so it's a Alpha to para toppling
the central Carbon Alpha,
right. Uh, with the Para position
of one of the benzene rings,
which are for avoids the steric hindrance.
Now,
how about the color? Remember that the
reason Gomberg thought it was this, this,
uh, uh, that it was this,
was that the radical was colored the
stuff that went away rapidly when you
swirled it, but the stuff that was in
equilibrium with that was not colored.
That's why the color went away,
but came back again when the
equilibrium was reestablished.
So the stuff that was in
equilibrium with was not colored.
This he thought should be colored,
right?
So he thought it couldn't be that
dimer and he was almost right.
This is the UV spectrum of that stuff.
So it has quite a strong
absorbance here at, uh,
three 18 nanometers,
but it Peters out just
at three 95 nanometers.
And as it turns out,
the ultraviolet,
the invisible part of the spectrum
ends at three 95 nanometers.
If it had been five nanometers more,
he would have seen the color of
that with his eye. So he was close,
but no cigar on that one. Right?
And because of that, for, for this,
for a whatever it, uh, uh, 46 years,
people had the wrong structure of this
important compound. Right now, in fact,
that's at minus 60 degrees where the
equilibrium lies toward the dimer,
away from the monomer. But if you
warm the 21 degrees, now you see the,
the absorption from the, from the
monomer. There's enough of it to see
that's at five, 13 nanometers. A S. Okay.
And the reason it's colored is not
because it has this crinoid structure,
which was his theory, but because
it has a non bonding. So Mo,
so normally you have bonding
and anti-bonding orbitals
Pi and Pi Star conjugated
ones, right? But this one has a non
bonding orbital right in the middle.
So a much smaller gap.
So the,
so the energy is much lower of the
quantum that gets absorbed by the free
radical. Okay. Now, uh,
this was published, did in that,
that thesis that appeared here, uh,
was published the next year in the
Journal of the American Chemical Society.
Almost word for word about the
color of the free radicals, right?
And this is the, the passage
of that. It says, uh,
the relationship between
color and constitution to
try fennel methyl or briefly
stated the following first that you have
a colored free radical in equilibrium
with the dimer hexa fan.
LFA Right. And second,
the color is attributed
to the Quinn oid tout him,
or we would now say resonance structure.
See.
So the color was attributed to that.
But notice what's interesting about
taking this paper from the dissertation to
the, to the printed form in the
Journal of American Chemical Society,
the published warm,
what got left out,
the correct structure,
the diamond.
So it was intentionally left
out because of this color,
the color thing, they, the, the,
the correct dimer was dropped for 46
years because they thought it should be
colored and it just almost was.
So I think that's an interesting
application of spectroscopy.
Okay. Now, third thoughts on the Friedel
crafts reaction. Whenever we had thoughts,
we had second thoughts. Uh, now
we have third thoughts. And uh,
the second thoughts just to,
to remind you was that when you
do a Friedel crafts reaction,
you could imagine benzine
me in a nucleophile and
displacing chloride from an
propyl to give and propyl
benzene and [inaudible].
And that would be an sn two reaction.
Or,
or you could imagine if it broke the
bond a little more that the hydride could
shift and you'd get
ice of pro ball either,
either with a aluminum chloride
tightly associated with it.
Or since it's a secondary, I
and may be much looser. Okay.
So that would be like an sn one
reaction that allowed the rearrangement.
But then we wondered what would happen
if we rotated, didn't had a meth.
I'd shift if we couldn't have a hydro.
If we instead of a hydride shift,
then we get the, if we had
the rearrangement, we get
the same thing back again.
It was still given propyl.
Uh, so the question is,
is it sn two or is it sn one?
And then there was this additional
complication that if the methyl got stuck
halfway in a cycle of propyl protonated,
cyclo propane,
a structure that still would give the
end propylene benzine. And in fact,
dino found in 1968 that you did that
and that it was randomly distributed
because the hydrogen can zip around the
periphery of the protonated cycle of
propane. Okay. So then I pose to you
a way to become famous of problem,
how to decide whether the,
whether the Friedel crafts reaction
really is an sn two where benzene is a
nucleophile and displaces
chloride from a thing like this.
Either before or after the meth I'd
shift or whether it's an sn one reaction.
Did anyone have an idea how to solve that?
Yeah.
Used to Tyrian.
Well, we could label to see where the
deuterium ends up in the end pro ball.
And what I found, since I've posed
you this way, to become a famous,
was it somebody actually
did that experiment, right?
It was done two years later in 1970
and it didn't make them famous,
right?
That the paper has been cited only twice
in the succeeding 40 years or whatever.
Okay.
And it was done by Lee Ann Woodcock in
Saskatchewan in 1970 so they've prepared
the one with deuterium here and they did
the reaction with aluminum chloride at
five degrees for four
Centigrade for 45 minutes.
That's near the freezing point of benzene.
So it's about,
it's cold as you can get if you're
going to use benzene as a solvent.
They also did it with
another inert solvent.
The idea is that that would
slow the nuclear file.
Would that be more dilute the
benzene that's doing the thing.
So it would slow down the displacement
reaction if it were an sn two.
Okay.
So what would you expect
if it had been
an sn two, an sn? Two reaction
without any rearrangement.
If it had just been benzene
being a nucleophile,
the only thing aluminum chloride does
is help the chloride be a good leaving
group.
Then where would the deuterium end up
here? Here, here.
One, two, three Australian.
What do you say?
We just did the exam.
You should fried on this.
It should be here,
right?
Halted. Benzine just comes to the
taxes. Carbon and chloride leaves.
Then the deuterium should all be there.
What if it undergoes a meth?
I'd shift right then
where would it be? Ashby.
Okay.
Material. Remember started
here, right? And then the meth
side shifted. If that's
the maximum. Some, yeah.
Then it would be here.
Right.
And what if it went through a
protonated cycle of propane?
All right?
Then it would be scrambled.
I already know what proteinated
cycle appropriate it would be.
So now by studying where the deuterium is,
we should be able to figure out of what
the mechanism is with that to give an
propyl benzene with an propyl chloride.
And what they found was that 90% of the
product was die deuterated there and
none of it was die deuterated elsewhere.
Right?
So it really is the case then that there's
less than 2% of partial or full meth.
I'd shift en route to and propyl benzene,
right?
It's just the simplest thing.
You think that it's forms by of benzene
nucleophile doing an sn two reaction.
Okay. Now why isn't that a 100%? Uh,
because other cad ions are
able to abstract hydride
from this position to make
this cat I had here and then the deuterium
to get washed out of the molecule.
But anyhow, that's, that's uh,
that's what they found. Uh, so,
uh,
you'll have to find out some other way
to become famous as an organic chemist.
Okay.
Now at the end last time we were doing
oxidation and reduction as bookkeeping.
Uh, not because there's
anything re real about it,
but because it could help
us to classify reagents.
We've been classifying reagents as
high homos, low Lumos, weak bonds,
for example, if you want to get
a free radical reaction, uh,
but there's a completely different
way of classify them in a,
in us a sense of very artificial way as
to whether they're oxidizing or reducing
agents.
So we went through a whole bunch of
reagents and classified them as oxidizing
reagents. The elemental
halogen die sulfide, uh, uh,
chromium trioxide reducing agents.
Uh,
methane is a reducing agent,
but it's,
it's not very reactive because didn't
have good homos are Lumos, right?
Free radicals are what we need to get
a foothold on that or lithium aluminum
hydride h minus sodium hydroxide,
potassium metal which can give up
electrons and r s h can give up,
uh, uh, can give up a h minus.
And we saw that when you oxidize back
and forth between die sulfide and,
and uh, thiol okay. But HCL,
Casey l the elements are in
their normal oxidation states,
so they're neither oxidizing,
reducing and it just at the end we
got to water and showed that in water
hydrogen is plus one and oxygen
is minus two. So it's neither,
right? Although, uh, and in fact
you can see that when it, uh,
the reaction of water with ethylene
catalyzed by acid and the carbon is minus
two minus two for ethylene,
after you've added it's
minus one minus three,
right?
So one carbon got oxidized but the other
carbon got reduced and there's no net
change, right? So you don't need
either an oxidizing or reducing agent,
right? Because there is no net change in
the oxidation step. So water can do that.
So,
but water does a work in oxidizing,
reducing, uh, scenarios. And in
particular a very important one.
Photosynthesis changes
oxidizes water to o two. Right?
But at the same time,
uh,
reduces the hydrogen and water to the
equivalent of h minus and that's nad takes
up the age to become Nad h and remember
we've talked about that being a source
of hydride h minus, right? So it
gets both oxidized and reduced.
Uh,
so not all reducing agents would work
satisfactorily is for any given reaction,
but it's typically few tile to try
a reagent from the wrong class.
You don't usually use bromine if
you need to do reduction, right. Or,
or a hydrogen chloride if you needed to
do either oxidation and reduction. Right.
So it can be a big help in narrowing
the field and choosing reagents.
Now I wanted to go to the board a little
bit to show oxidation states this was
done, uh, in the class last year
by Professor Siegel from Zurich,
but I thought it was handy to do and
I will do it again on the board here.
Uh, that one and it, this one? Yeah. Okay.
So let me just put this screen up.
Okay.
And don't, I guess for the far
enough, we'll see. I think I can.
And can I blank that video mute.
Okay.
So we, we've, we've talked
about, uh, about arranging a,
uh, uh, let's see there. One other,
so there's one other set center.
There we go.
Okay.
No,
he chose to use ch four c h three o h c
h to formic acid and CO2 as examples of
oxidation levels carbon.
Let's just do it a little differently.
Not that it's better or worse,
but let's just have an r on there.
So we get to have our c h three.
Okay.
What's the oxidation level of the carbon?
Remember how we do with accounting or
bookkeeping if you have another car,
but attached to it they shared that
the pair of electrons evenly,
no contribution to oxidize and state.
But if it's hydrogen, hydrogen gives its
electron to carbon and making the bond.
So this carbon will be plus three
minus three minus three.
Pardon me.
Thanks for being on your toes.
Okay.
Then we could have our c,
h two o h.
Okay.
Okay. So the oxygen cancels one of
the carbons. So this'll be minus one.
Notice we're going in steps of
two here, right? Is the same,
but when I went up there,
but I've,
I've decided to put an r on instead
of one of the H's just for variety.
So now r,
c h double bond o right now it's plus one.
Hey, because you have two
oxygens, one hydrogen,
then we could go r a,
c o, o, h, a carboxylic acid,
now it's plus three.
All right.
And at the very end you can go to CEO
to then you don't have the are in there
and that's plus four as it
says up there. Okay. Now let's,
uh,
let's look at different classes of
compounds at their levels of oxidation.
So we could have alkanes.
Yeah,
so we could have, uh, uh, let's see,
we've already got a r c h
three. Okay, so minus three.
So we'll check that one.
Okay.
Now can we have an alkane which has the,
the oxidation state of carbon minus one.
So it'd be a carbon that has
all bonds to carbon, right?
Except one bond,
the hydrogen.
So a way to do that
would be to have R, c, h,
double bond, O, c, h, r. So on.
He
and then we could go to Al [inaudible],
a r c Si are.
So this would be
El con
and each of these is is minus one.
Overall it's minus two.
And each of these is zero.
Okay.
Right
now
what this means is
that
that if you wanted to get an alkene,
it has the same oxidation
level as the alcohol.
Right.
I got that right.
Actually, I should have worked
this through better ahead of time.
MMM.
It works.
That one works better in his scheme.
But notice that you could re the ALC,
uh,
you can get a or another
alkene would be r,
c h c h two.
Right.
Uh,
so this one you can get from
here just by a reaction.
We know.
What's the reaction that would go from
the Alkane to the alkene from the alcohol.
Yeah.
How do you get there?
What do you call that reaction
to start with an Alkane, an
apartment. This, this is art.
This will be our pride because
the sea as part of the are here,
right?
Yeah.
So this one involves ill,
it's an elimination reaction.
You just treat it with acid,
you don't need an oxidizing
or reducing agent. Right.
And if you do, uh, and so,
so the idea is that you can
go down this way with neither,
but if you have to go back and
forth this way, you do oxidation.
Yeah.
Or reduction.
Right.
So you could have outfield,
hey lines,
right?
So here at you at have our x,
And this would be the,
the carbon in the rx would be minus one.
Right?
The carbon that's attached to do the acts,
that is the ex ex nurse of it is
minus one. Right. Let me make,
I should make an RCH too.
Sorry.
Okay.
And how do we get,
say the bromide from the alcohol,
what reagent do we use?
Pbr three
or that
are the chloride, s o c l two. These
are not oxidizing or reducing agents.
Right? The, the elements are in
there. A normal thing. So we can,
we can go down without using
an oxidizing or reducing agent.
You wouldn't, uh, now how,
how could we get from here,
from an Alkane over to here.
How would you put bromine in?
Say what reagent did you use?
Alipay in one way can help you overall
what reagent? No, that's,
that's very good.
If you have an Alkane,
so ch bonds and you want to make CBR.
Anybody remember a reaction to do that?
What's the problem?
And reacting an alkane.
They're not reacted. Why. Dot.
No high homos. Low Lumos, right?
No functional group. How do you get at
something that's not a functional group?
How do you get up the hydrogens?
You can't use combos at Lumos.
How would you change methane
in de Methyl Bromide?
Yeah,
we are two cl two.
What's up?
Free radical chain reaction.
Right?
But notice the things you're using
br two cl l two are oxidizing agents,
right? So to go across in this direction
from one column to the next, you use,
you'd need oxidation,
right?
Or You could do another
oxidation and get r c h x two,
right?
And that would require from here doing
a second free radical substitution.
But if you came down from
the Aldehyde to get there,
it's the same oxidation level. So you
don't need something like bromine, right.
To get from here down to
here. How bout a few, uh, uh,
we could do alcohols too
and of course we could not go also to the,
to the tribe bromide,
r c c a x three say,
and that we could get
from an acid right?
Without using an oxidizing
or reducing agent.
But if we have to get it from anything
over here from an alcohol or from an
Aldehyde, we have to do oxidation
to get that somewhere. Okay.
On the ultimate one is a co two would
be carbon tetrachloride for example.
That's the company that's completely
oxidized for them. Or if we have, uh,
uh, Alfio hides alcohols
here, we had an alcohol,
right?
Uh,
let's suppose we made a
dial r a o h taken twice
and with h in here, r c
h o h taken twice, right?
That if we've started from an alcohol
to get that we have to do an oxidation,
choose an oxidizing agent.
But if we could make it
from an Aldehyde without,
without using an oxidizing
and reducing agent.
Can you think of any way of going from
an Aldehyde to a carbon that has two
alcohols on it?
Do you remember what you call a
carbon that has two o h is on it?
Agenda dial.
Where do you get it?
MMM,
we need to do an observation
like rolling or something. No,
we immediately see you don't
because they're in the same column.
Same observation level.
So you remember what the
what, how, how do you make
the dial for me? Let's, let's uh,
r c o h and I want to get r,
c. O, h. O. H. H.
What do I do first?
Derek
protonate the oxygen protonate the oxygen
plus charge here.
And then an o h minus comes in
the talks with this. Oh, H minus.
So we bad at h plus a h mindless.
It's more likely that in,
if you're using acid ketalysis that
there's very little low h minus around.
Right, because the acid
would have reacted with it.
So what would you normally use?
Used to come here to make the CEO bond,
see the water and the water right.
And then lose a proton.
So the protons,
just a catalyst. Right? Uh, so, but, but
notice what we're using is just water
an h plus thousands or Ooh,
minus ketalysis eat too.
You can have hydroxide ed first and
then this pulls a proton off water.
Okay.
So,
so you go up and down using just
water and the acid things that aren't
oxidizing, reducing agents. So you
can see how that might work out,
that if you create in your,
on your study sheet a list of
oxidation levels of, of things.
And uh,
then you could see it when you're
faced with a given problem, uh,
weather what kind of
reagent you need to choose.
And if you can simplify to a third of the
reagents, you know, that's a big help.
Okay. Now, uh, so that's
just the bookkeeping.
There's also the question of the
mechanism by which you do this.
So let's just consider br
two as an oxidizing agent.
So if you have an owl cane,
a r,
c h three say and you
react it with VR too,
to get the an oxidized form,
r c h two B are,
what's the mechanism by which you
do it? We just did this, Chris.
It's a free ride. All
right, so we get B R. Dot.
Taking the hydrogen and we've,
we've done this before.
You got the radical and then so free
radical chain reactions that bromines
oxidizing agent, but acting the
somo. It's different with alcohol's.
Let's suppose we have VR too.
Yes.
And we want to react with an alcohol.
How does the reaction begin?
I mean it would be possible to do it
by a free radical reaction. Right?
If you had, if you put in an
initiator, get chains going,
it would be possible to do it,
but there's a better reaction
to react VR too with ethanol.
And how does that begin?
Maybe what makes B are too reactive.
Hi Hobo. Lumo what's high?
What's low?
Not many orbitals there. Sigma
Star. Okay, so we got signals
star here
and what's high homo then of the alcohol?
Yeah, fiction. Lone pair. On
the, Oh, okay. So long pair on,
yeah.
Let's see how these work.
Yeah.
The Pr, pardon me. Um,
attacks the sigma star. That takes
about the VR, right? I want to do this.
A red, actually that's no
better read than the other one.
Okay. So this comes in here
and these leave and we've,
we've seen things like this forever.
So we have h O,
B r and that,
let me write this with this unshared
pair just for, to be cumbersome about it.
Okay. And Bromide came away
and there's a plus charge here.
How do we get rid of the plus charge?
Maybe you're doing it
in age. Yep. Perfect Bro.
So now we got, Oh, br. Oh,
I was gonna make that
ch two
ch three.
Okay.
And here we got this
at fair.
And now can you see
anything that this might do?
What reactions, if we see we had, when
we have Adam's next to one another,
bromine on one hydrogen on the other
two reactions.
So we have some
base, it doesn't have to be a strong
base, it could just be the alcohol,
uh,
or it could be the bromide
that we lost here. Okay.
So this can take the h,
this goes in and these go on the bromine,
bromine.
So now we have,
yeah,
double bond o.
This h is still there,
c h three
and bromide,
which has that pair of electrons.
Yeah.
So we've oxidized the alcohol
to the Aldehyde. Right.
We've gone from here to here.
Okay.
And notice what the trick was that the
first oxidations and reductions we talked
about where electron transfer
and actual electron transfer,
like from a metal to a, to a sigma
star bond about how he'll haylight.
Right here we're transferring electrons,
but in pairs,
the electron start
belonging to the oxygen.
Then they're shared between
the oxygen and the bromine,
and then they leave with the bromine.
So the bromine came in and took a
pee and shared a pair of electrons,
then went away carrying them away.
Right?
So it removed this pair of electrons
and that's how the oxidation occurred.
Okay. So that's just an, so
the, these reactions are just,
this is an sn two reaction.
Yeah.
And this is an e two reaction.
So they're just normal mechanisms, but
because of the way we look at it, it's a,
it's a oxidation reduction reaction.
Uh,
okay.
And now cro three,
chromium six.
Let's see what this way
that reminds you a little bit of a Ketone,
right?
The CRM.
So you could imagine adding water
to give cr.
Oh, Oh, oh h.
O. H. Okay.
What's the oxidation state if the
chromium is oxidation state here?
What's its oxidation state here?
Still
still plus six.
You know,
you could add a photo box to use water
to be the same observation state.
All right. Or You could,
uh, you could imagine, uh,
making having two of these.
So these are a little bit like alcohol's
you could imagine to make an ether from
that.
So you could have cr,
oh, CR, right?
With a o.
O h.
O.
O. O. O. H.
So this is a chromium trioxide,
chromic acid,
dichromate and so on. So there are lots
of different forms, or you can get,
if you reacted it with Hcl,
you could
protonate lose, lose water,
add the chlorine instead.
So you could get c, r, O, O, c,
l, O, h.
But all of these are just different
disguises of the same thing.
Chromium six.
Okay.
Now let's consider the reaction of any
of these with an alcohol like a h o c h,
two ch three,
right?
So we can have the unshared pair
and I'll do it in red again,
right?
Attack the chromium.
So we got
h o
CR, no bond, no double bond. O,
uh
Oh minus or Ooh,
let's do the o h
right?
And now notice that we're in the
same business we were with bromine.
We have now, uh, let me,
let me write this out so that it
looks like the one over there.
H H.
So now we can bring up some base,
uh,
take this age.
This goes in here and the chromium
leaves with that pair of electrons,
right? So again, just as before,
we'll let, we'll have lost the proton.
It looks just like what happened
over there. The chromium came in,
shared the pair of electrons
and then left with them.
And the elimination reaction,
right? So again, it's a, it's,
it's oxidation oxidation. And if you
look at the chromium chromium afterwards,
it's CR. Oh, oh, Oh age,
right? And what's, uh, my right here?
A minus.
Yeah.
So it's got one, two, three, four, five.
It's giving to oxygen, but it gets
an electron back with the minus.
So this is plus four.
Yeah.
So chromium goes from plus six plus
four in the process of doing this,
this, uh, oxidation. Okay.
Now there's a problem in doing
this to make an Aldehyde.
And the problem is that
if you're, if you're, uh,
when you're working in water,
if the pro,
the product you're going to
get here from this elimination,
you've lost this proton,
you'll lose this h break this bond.
So you have c double Bondo.
No.
If that's what you want to make,
there's a problem because Aldehydes,
you know,
have an equilibrium constant
about one with water.
So this is going to add
water to make a dial.
Yeah.
And why is that a problem?
Because alcohol's
react with chromium trioxide to get
oxidized. So you would, you could,
you could, uh, uh, uh, lose, lose this,
uh,
so this option and give up.
It's pair of electrons get oxidized.
You've lose this age and this age.
And then you would have
o h c double bond o
so you over oxidize.
Yeah,
right. All the way to the carboxylic
acid. We go on another step up there.
Now how can you avoid that problem?
Let me
ask you this one.
This one.
Okay.
You could do
it by making this, the
reagent shown here. Whoops.
Uh,
video
pira Denny young chloro chromate so
notice you added Hcl to cro three,
which made chromic chloro chromic acid,
and then the proton has given to
parody and to make a Pyridium cad at.
Now that is organic enough that it's
readily soluble in organic solvents,
right?
Which the other forms of chromium that
we talked about or not now can you see
what advantage that PR that might
provide to do it in an organic
salt
water?
So the reagent is called all
period idiom chloro chromate and here's
an example where you get a 92% yield of
the Aldehyde from an a straight chain
alcohol use in period end IOM crow,
chloro chromate.
The crucial thing is the solvent is
methylene chloride ch two cl two,
right?
No water,
no gem dial and therefore
no over oxidation because
the mechanism requires the
alcohol to react with.
Okay,
I took that example from Loudon's
textbook. However, if you,
so textbooks often, uh, I
have no doubt that, that,
that that happened and that they got
92% yield. But as a general reaction,
there can be a problem. If you look
at what Wikipedia says about this,
there seems to be the voice of
experience writing. It says in practice,
the chromium byproduct deposits with
peer Dean is a sticky black tar,
which can complicate matters.
You've gotten a rose colored
picture in your lab. I mean you're,
you've often had frustrations.
I know,
but those reactions are carefully chosen
so you don't get sticky black stars.
But you find very often, and when you
try to do something in organic chemistry,
you get something that's very difficult
to filter or deal with and that that can
happen in this reaction.
But anyhow, period,
any employer and chromate is what
you use on an exam when it's asked,
how are you going to oxidize and
alcohol to an Aldehyde without getting a
carboxylic acid? Now you can have, oh,
sorry. We're going to have to carry
on with this next time. Thanks.